à 20 ans il avait une belle carrière de
pâtissier devant lui jusqu'à ce qu'un
terrible accident le prive d'une jambe
deux ans après pourtant malgré cette
épreuve alexis peut de nouveau
travailler la rééducation un mental
d'acier et le soutien indéfectible de
son patron un employeur qui investit son
argent personnel pour le revoir à ses
côtés le récit à la chapelle vendômoise
de paul boyer alors là du bon vin
chapelle vendômoise un petit village de
700 habitants
ah oui à la victime d'un grave accident
de moto en 2019
alexis a dû être amputé de la jambe
gauche pendant sa rééducation
ce jeune boulanger pâtissier ne pensait
qu'à une chose pouvoir un jour reprendre
le travail
[Musique]
depuis trois semaines ils retrouvent le
sourire éclaire paris-brest tarte aux
framboises
il vit de nouveau de sa passion mais le
chemin a été long car rien n'était gagné
[Musique]
paris aux économies
durant son séjour à l'hôpital
son patron lui rend visite chaque
semaine très proches l'un de l'autre
david a rapidement déceler le talent
hors norme du jeune apprenti et n'a pas
voulu s'en séparer
j'ai dit qu'on lançait le projet et
qu'on y allait en fait du coup ça l'a
boosté de l'autre côté lui pour la
rééducation
donc en fait on on chemine et chacun de
notre côté lui en rééducation mois sur
les travaux pour avoir voilà un seul
objectif c'est qu'ils apprennent qu'ils
reprennent le boulot avec sa nouvelle
prothèse alexis peut désormais se
déplacer mais impossible de soulever des
charges lourdes pendant deux ans david a
transformé le garage en fournil
accessible et installer de nouvelles
machines adaptées montant des coûts
160000 euros
donc on a commencé à chiffrer à essayer
de regarder un petit peu ce qu'on
pouvait faire et et puis aussi pour
montrer notre volonté pour pouvoir avoir
d être derrière fallait que je montre un
peu ma bonne foi et mon envie d'aller
jusqu'au bout du projet four à pain
chambre avec chariot sol antidérapant la
boulangerie est presque entièrement
adapté pour alexis mais david va aller
plus loin en continuant à équiper son
commerce pour faciliter l'accès aux
personnes handicapées
nous on est les premiers à dire on ne
porte pas aussi à des stagiaires les
personnes handicapées qui veulent
essayer de venir refaire un petit peu
d'insertion en entreprises font tout à
fait prêts à les accueillir
aujourd'hui alexis est définitivement
remis sur pied et confie timidement
qu'il aimerait beaucoup reprendre un
jour la moto mais uniquement sur circuit